alors donc je vais pas vous interviewez
vous allez faire quand vous êtes un très
bon intérieur vous êtes un des maîtres
benji est mon maître quand j'étais petit
il ya très très longtemps un vous étiez
vous auto interviewé c'est sûr
posez vous des questions il répondait
ainsi à la première question que je me
pose c'est pourquoi dire du mal de moi
oui bon ben parce que je suis sûr que je
me ferais jamais de procès j'ai envie de
me demander qui auriez-vous aimé être et
là je répond sans hésiter un grand brun
avec un polo noir question alors plus
angoissante quel est le désagrément
d'être philippe bouvard et bien je suis
condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin avec
quelqu un qu autrement j'aurais sûrement
pas fréquentes
j'aurais aussi envie de me demander ce
que je reproche aux femmes
eh bien je reproche aux femmes ce que
drieu la rochelle reprocher aux femmes
qu'ils avaient aimé c'est à dire d'être
assez peu exigentes pour se contenter de
moi
la question qui généralement vient à la
fin d'une interview bien menée et la
vôtre a été fabuleuse celle que son
grand-père de goût et bien c'est une
idée mieux que j'ai fait et si c'était à
refaire
oui avant que koné et bien j'irai chez
lagaf le dialogue est plus facile merci
philippe bouvard c'est la première fois
que je tentais l'expérience de l'auto
interview avec vous je peux pas me
tromper merci beaucoup
vous connaissez le dernier à leur jeu
derrière deux je les ai connus avant que
ce soit un film honnête j'ai beaucoup
aimé et j'adore mais pitié